up next this is from Roman from Tulsa he
said in debate club this was a little
different he didn't follow the format
but I think we can make an exception for
this guy Judy super cute how old is that
guy probably 7 but what was the question
of who your favorite restaurant favorite
wrestlers wov dude I grew up were you a
WWII a big boss man baby big boss man I
was my friend
I was a Macho Man Randy dude legit I
like Tim and the warrior
those are my face Ultimate Warrior's the
best me my brother would act like the
bash brothers oh yeah yeah you drink a
bunch of kool-aid and put our tongues
out we're still doing that yeah we run
into each other get brain trauma and one
thing that was cool was I remember Scott
Steiner and uh the Steiner Brothers from
NWA I was never into ma what was the
other Wrestling Federation call WCW my
brain is slaughtered at WCW that's
always slow there's the WWE WWF WCW a
NWA it was a national wrestling
association we looked at it please dear
I don't know if I'm insane or if that's
a real thing that I know no you're right
NWA is a realtor but NWA I thought was a
group they were a group in music but I
know but no you're right though deal cuz
that's where that's where uh bogan
National Wrestling Alliance are you
right though you were right though cuz
that's all players bang yeah that's well
games Hollywood Hulk Hogan at NWA really
yeah cuz they had the Steiner Brothers
in there and those guys were uh they
were yeah both hi Steve you're always
dressed like high school wrestlers they
had on the unit or that's cool with the
things over their ears you do cover your
ears cuz I'm it's gonna get a little
graphic but kid when I was a kid I used
to jack off disabled from WWE
sable Oh bro she's made Brock lesner now
but dude in her heyday
[Laughter]
he put cable yeah fake milk bags I think
they're real there look nice huh no I
think they're real now remember I was
like nine so that was cool when I was
nine now my coach he looks ridiculous
now she looks like an [ __ ] when I was
nine
between that and Mercedes rap album oh
dude
bus Ville yeah population this guy Thank
You Man dude cmonn sir made impressive
nuts
Macho Man Randy Savage I think I liked I
really liked who was probably one of my
favorites I think you'd be like an
undertaker guy
no I was back out like our darts I liked
the ultimate warrior I don't like the
Undertaker
I like the Ultimate Warrior I feel like
we're forgetting someone let's see Bret
the Hitman Hart
Andre the Giant I like Brutus the barber
beefcake I liked him and let her know
the animal did you all guy oh I like
mankind I don't remember
mankind he put a sock on and it's not
that's where he got dumb I think I liked
it when they had a boss man he was a
real police officer and I like oh beware
I remember the guy with the birds oh
yeah dude how about Jake the snake
oh yeah Jake's Incas great man Jake the
snake was cool they could snake was
great I think um but then when I was
like 10 I realized his fake I was so
brokenhearted were you yeah yeah I was
bummed out you seem like something we
get brokenhearted when they found out
wrestling's fake
exactly who you are dude yeah see you in
there I was sad dude mmm god I used to
bust nuts to that though Jesus pick a
path did you cry I do there was a
confusing time for the kids I'm fluid in
your body bro yeah you're right I'm
saying you ready hydrate yeah when you
write you ready bro cat who's your
favorite wrestler did your females have
a favorite wrestler there weren't a lot
when I was young female wrestlers I
didn't really have a favorite female
wrestler I liked Stone Cold Steve Austin
Attitude Era well I think watching the
emails rustle were my favorite parts I
don't know I like watching cat let me
ask you this do you like watching women
fighting you see yeah that's cool that's
your thing yeah I do not like that I
don't like it either it's not a sexist
thing I just grew up different where I'm
not used to it so when I see females
like in violence it proto reasons like
ah [ __ ] dude especially if they're hot
we'll also throw them all care about the
lair it seems to it's just too much yeah
I just saw yeah I don't like seeing
women fight each other and let's have a
sword and a shield I don't like I'm
seeing punch each other like even in
Game of Thrones the big the big butch
one the female 1 oh yeah I know she got
dick down
she's like Chris Mullins kind of that
lady and he grew his hair out no she
looked like Lottie debauch no she did
not
you don't know
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]